Very good afternoon to all of you.
Class is at 3:40.
I think some of you join at 3:30.
classes at 340. So anyway,
we will start in one or two minutes.
I just finished my previous class as some
of you were there, so you know.
So we will start in 2 minutes.
But I think.
Okay, I'm just opening the slides.
Just give me two minutes.
I presented.
Okay, very good afternoon to all of you.
How many of you attended the expert
session that we arranged for NLP
applications?
I attended.
Just raise your hands or yeah.
Okay, yeah, there was a good number,
I think, for the expert session.
So thank you for joining.
I hope all of you enjoyed the session.
Yes, madam, he was teaching very well.
It was useful, right?
Yes, ma'am. Yes.
Yes, ma'am.
Very good, very good. Great, great.
Happy to hear that.
Nice, nice. Okay, thank you.
So I'm glad that all of you attended and
he was actually highly impressed and that
made me feel proud about you all.
So he said that your students are very
good and very curious and the interaction
was very, he enjoyed it basically.
So, I mean,
it's nice that you all interacted with
him in a very nice, positive way.
So he was very happy about that.
And I felt proud to say that you guys are
my students.
So I just wanted to share that with all
of you.
Now coming to today's contact session.
So today's contact session is going to be
in line.
with the expert session that we had.
And so this is going to be a very useful
and important topic in industry.
I think I say that to most of the topics,
but as you will realize it,
as you finish your MTech AMIN and start
working in this area,
all of these topics that we discuss in
respective courses,
whether it is NLP applications,
conversational AI.
Majority of the MTech AIML courses have a
lot of industry applications,
and that's the reason we have designed
the curriculum in that manner.
So in the same way,
information extraction has a wide number
of applications in the industry,
and we are going to look at.
the different aspects of information
extraction. It's a broad topic,
information extraction that can be
treated as a course itself,
but we always have challenges in MTech,
AMOL already.
We have too many electives and too few
lecture slots, exam slots.
So operationally also,
it's always a challenge for all of us.
finding a faculty,
finding a learning facilitator,
designing courses.
So it's not an easy thing for all of us.
And we constantly think and revise the
curriculum to ensure that we teach what
is relevant. At the same time,
it's not overwhelming for all of you.
So that's the reason this information.
in extraction topic,
we have divided into 3 contact sessions.
So today I will be focusing completely on
named entity recognition. Dr.
Ashish has already touched upon it in the
expert session,
but I will try to add some more inputs on
whatever he has already told you all.
Next session will be completely focusing
on relation extraction,
which is again very, very critical. No,
I am not, I am not, I am not.
Are you sharing some, Madam,
you're not sharing your script?
I will be sharing it.
So I just wanted to reiterate that this
information extraction module that we are
going to discuss is going to
span across three contact sessions.
So NER is going to be covered today along
with implementation if at all possible.
Next session will be relation extraction
and the third session will be focusing on
temporal or event data extraction.
All these three have wide industry
applications. So I was just checking
whether in agentic AI. So in fact,
it is said that in agentic AI application,
information extraction is extremely
critical to design the agentic workflows
and also calling of the tools, etc.
So information extraction plays a very
critical role even in agentic AI.
systems.
So that is what I just wanted to give it
as a background,
the reason for including this topic and
spanning it across three contact sessions.
Because otherwise it becomes overwhelming
to cover everything in one contact
session and then I'll have to just rush.
So that's the reason I've kept it
separately.
Okay,
so coming to today's contact session
slides, now I have shared.
Are you able to see?
Yes, ma'am.
Yes, yes, ma'am.
Okay, okay, thank you. So to start with,
in today's contact session,
first we will look at what is information
extraction first.
Then we will look at what are its
application,
what are the challenges that we have.
Then we will focus on NER in particular.
with the challenges of NER,
approaches of NER, and also evaluation.
So everywhere,
evaluation plays a very important role.
So we are going to focus here on NER
evaluation.
So we will talk about first to start with.
So before I move on,
let me just take a very quick
brush up, what is information extraction?
Now those of you who attended the session
should be able to tell me at least
something about it.
Can you tell me what is information
extraction?
Get some relevant documents from the
corpus.
Extract relevant.
Relevant documents.
from a document corpus or relevant text
from a document.
Or...
Relevant team.
Yes, yes,
the relevant text from the document.
Not entire document, but relevant, say,
kind of words, exact words,
extracting important keywords or key
information from the documents.
That is information extraction.
Okay, so do you remember what he covered?
How do you, do you remember?
I think he had also talked about named
entity. I think he talked about that,
right?
Business, business.
Yes, ma'am.
What is named entity?
Identifying a place or a technology or
otherwise a person.
Something like lasers.
So, I, yeah, identities.
Asleep proper down.
A problem, yeah, names.
Yes, proper noun. Correct.
So can you give example?
Then.
Person, organization, locations.
Like.
Name of the city.
Yes, correct, correct. Bids, Pilani,
Chetana, NLP Applications,
Yeah.
conversationally,
I am giving some random examples,
but all of these are named entities. Okay,
so typically proper nouns,
But.
so it would be an organization,
as somebody said, name, place,
organization.
I remembered the game we used to play.
So it could be a name, proper name,
like a first name or a place name or
organization name,
or it could be other than these as well.
So typically these three are the most
common ones,
but of course you have a lot many more
named entities apart from these three as
well. Say name of a disease,
name of a legal clause,
name of a technology,
There are other named entities other than
name of a person, place, and organization.
So that's the basic point of named entity
recognition.
You want to extract these important named
entities from a piece of text. Okay?
So that is what we are going to look at
today.
So in general,
when you look at information extraction,
not particularly for named entity,
in general,
information extraction is identifying
pieces of important or relevant
information or data in unstructured or a
semi-structured text document.
Now, of course,
this also applies to audio information
extraction, video extraction,
image information extraction,
and so on and so forth. That is,
that cannot be,
everything cannot be covered under one
umbrella.
So here we are going to focus on text
because that's a major chuck.
80% of the stuff on web is.
text. Okay,
so we want to extract this important
pieces of information from this
structured, unstructured,
or semi-structured textual document.
That is our purpose. Now,
textual document could be PDF,
it could be CSV, it could be PPT,
it could be Word doc, it could be JSON,
not JSON, sorry,
JSON is a structured format.
But all of these are textual contents.
It could be Excel sheet as well.
So when we want to get important
structured pieces of information from
this unstructured,
we call it as information extraction.
Now the text not only could be in
different formats like Doc, PDF and all,
it could also span across multiple
domains, multiple applications.
like web scrape, web pages, HTML pages,
scientific articles, blogs,
newspaper articles, messages,
classified advertisements,
medical records,
say your medical transcripts,
academic transcripts.
So it could be any such, even your bills,
right?
your shops, the bills,
all of these are the text that you could
have as an input to your information
extraction system. Okay,
now NLP and extract information
extraction are very much connected to
each other because you are going to use a
lot of NLP techniques for.
information extraction.
So including pause tagging, parsing,
although they may not be explicitly used
in your LLMs, transformers,
which is a black box,
implicitly the attention mechanism is
ultimately capture these relations via
parsing,
relations via pause tags and so on. Okay,
so they are tightly connected to each
other and they help each other,
both of them. So knowledge graphs,
will help in information extraction and
information extraction will help in
building the knowledge graph and so on
and so forth.
We'll talk about that shortly.
So in short,
information extraction is identifying
pieces of structured information.
So extracting information like who wrote
this article, what is this article about,
where did this incident happen?
And when did this happen?
How did it happen?
So a lot of these important pieces of
information can be automatically
extracted. By the way,
I forgot to mention automatic word.
You are automatically extracting the
information from this unstructured data
using various algorithms and various
tools.
Okay,
so that's the idea behind this
information extraction. Now,
these are some examples.
So the information that you are
extracting, as somebody correctly said,
could be name of a place,
it could be name of an organization.
As I told you,
it could also be other named entities,
like whether what is the position of that
person in that organization.
is also a named entity. Okay,
so this is one example. Sorry,
this is not a named entity.
This is a relation which you could
extract from the pieces of information.
So information extraction is not
restricted to named entities,
but it is also extracting the relations.
It is extracting the temporal events and
so on.
Okay,
so all that will come under the umbrella
of information extraction.
Basically filling the slots or the
segments of a particular database or
vector data store from this unstructured
data that you have. Okay,
now do you think,
how will you do this as the...
Ashish, Dr. Ashish, I think he was very,
he's a ******** faculty or a teacher,
so he was teaching quite well.
How will you do it?
How will you extract these pieces of
information if I want to do it?
How will I do it? See,
all this could be named entities.
How will the machine know that this is
not a named entity?
This is not a named entity.
How will the machine know this
information?
Or how will it know that Microsoft is a
named entity?
Microsoft Bill Gate is a named entity.
How will the machine know this?
Started with classification, madam.
Started with classification.
Automatically.
POS tagging.
Yes, one is simplest, one is POS tax.
You can find that if it is a proper noun,
then it is a particular,
but then how will you find out?
This is together, right?
Trustering classification.
It will just tell you the proper noun,
right?
Yeah, classification is like for what?
Dictionary.
What letter?
A particular category.
Why do you need classification here?
I will be tagging.
But there is a name of an organization,
name of a person, and classify them.
Yes, very good.
Those are my classes to identify what
That's a proper known.
type of named entity.
So there are two things that you need to
do here. First,
you have to find out the text in this
particular unstructured text,
which is a named entity.
That is your first job.
So which are the pieces of text in my
input text, which are named entities.
And then I also need to identify the type
of named entity. Okay,
so I need to segment and find out what is
the named entity.
Then I need to classify whether this is a
place or an organization or a name of a
person. What is it? Okay,
now this I'm talking about in the context
of named entities.
The same will apply for relations.
I first need to find out, okay,
this is a relation. This particular thing,
like CEO, is a relation,
and the type of relation is whatever is
the category, right? So I need to,
every time in information extraction,
I need to 1st find out what are the named
entities,
what is the pieces of information.
that are of importance to us.
And secondly,
I need to categorize or classify them.
Both the things are required, right?
And also there is a association or
relations between. So I extract, okay,
all these are named entities.
This is named entity,
this is named entity,
this is named entity, and so on.
But then I need to classify, okay, okay,
these entities are related to each other.
These entities are not related.
So for example,
maybe Richard Stallman and Bill Gates or
Microsoft is not related. Okay,
Free Software Foundation and Microsoft is
not related. Something like that.
How will I know that?
Right, so I need to do this association,
I need to do the classification,
and I need to do a segmentation for any
information extraction problem. Okay,
so that's the first thing that I need to
do.
So typically now all this is done at one
go by using the LLM model.
So we are going to look at the approaches.
starting with the rule based to the LLM
based or agentic AI also.
So currently the agentic system,
you just give some text as the input like
this and it will automatically come up
with this,
but you will not know how it has
extracted, right?
So internally it is using transformers
attention.
mechanism,
you need the training data for the named
entities and so on to extract it.
But nevertheless, finally,
what you want is you want to find out the
pieces of text,
whether you do it by agentic, DL, ML,
any approach.
These are the things that you need to do.
You need to extract the text,
you need to classify and associate them.
So typically the pipeline, yes, please,
please ask.
One doubt here. And one doubt here.
So name entity recognition may happen
with the help of the 1st letter
recognition, whether the letter,
the name or the proper noun is starting
with a capital letter. Yes. Yeah,
capital letter. That is one of the clues.
Yes.
but it is applicable only in the English
language. In case of other languages,
Yes, very good question.
Very good question. Yes,
it may not be applicable.
Indian languages will have to use another
this. You are right.
So that rule will be only applicable to
English. So for Indian languages,
Yeah, so...
you will have to look up for another
strategy, related languages and so on.
OK, OK,
we'll use different strategy for
Yeah.
different languages. OK, OK. Thank you,
ma'am.
Yes, yes, you will have to use that. Yes.
Also,
you might have to use for short form
something else for a dictionary.
So generally for,
I'll tell you in the end,
I have an application, real world,
where all of this is used in combination.
So dictionary, rules, agent, LLM,
transformer, DLM, and all.
All of them is together used for
application.
You can use them as together also.
So as you rightly said, for English,
whatever rules you define may not be
applicable. So rule has that problem.
Rule may not even be applicable across
domains. OK,
so those are challenges that we have.
That's why people go for LLM,
which are more generic. But LLM will need.
A lot of compute power and a lot of money.
So for simple things like extension or
country names,
you could as well use a dictionary.
Why go for a LAL model just to detect the
country name when you can easily do it
using dictionary, right? So you are right.
So you will have to defer it for the
Indian languages. You cannot use for it.
English rules for the Indian languages.
So that's also one of the areas of
research. I'm going to touch upon that.
NER for Indian languages. So okay,
so now typically in any information
extraction,
it may not be always in this flow,
the arrowed flow. Earlier,
before the LLM models or the agentic AI,
it used to happen in this pipeline
fashion.
But today, of course,
they do it in parallelly.
The transformers can detect the NER in
parallel, detect the relations,
in parallel, detect the events and so on.
So earlier, okay,
this core reference resolution is also
important. I'll touch upon it. Basically,
named entity recognition is finding the
named entities like we discussed.
Microsoft, Bill Gates, and so on.
Relation extraction is what we said,
like CEO, VP, or a parent of teachers,
the student takes this course,
opt for this course,
working in this organization.
All this is all relations. So typically,
if you see,
the verbs will form the relations,
the proper nouns will form the named
entities,
and there is this concept of event also,
which is temporal, which is temporal.
time dependent.
We'll talk about that as well. Okay,
so actually event is a special type of
relations,
which also indicates the temporal or
timestamp or time associated with it.
So typically the IE pipeline will have
all of these three,
named entity recognition, relation,
as well as event detection. Earlier,
this was template filling is like
populating the database or knowledge
graph. Once you extract all of these.
information from your unstructured text.
Okay,
and then so that it can be used for
further applications like conversational
AI, question answering,
machine translation, and so on.
So that is the overall IE pipeline or the
steps or the things that you need to do
in information extraction.
Now coming to the problems or challenges
that the information extraction has.
So it's not that simple because the
format.
So when you do a production ready
environment,
you will see that something works,
your whatever.
automated, say,
even the small language model,
which are extracting data very well from,
say, a Word document,
but may not be able to do so from a web
page,
because web page may have a lot of
formatting like this.
So how is it going to extract?
It's not like a straightaway information,
right? So what is the junk?
What is the relevant information?
How do you extract it?
It's not that easy to do it from a
different formatted kind of a content.
Plus, there could be something like this,
right? Snippets.
So how do you extract information from
these kinds of information?
Then there could also be tabular
information graph. So today,
these PI PDF and all of these.
libraries, they are able to extract very,
I mean, comparatively very good,
but we were trying for one of our
projects,
real world projects for financial
documents from the financial documents.
We could hardly extract relevant
information using these ready-made APIs
or tools,
even though they're using transformers.
we could not get very good quality output
using these models.
So real world problems,
real world scenario,
these different approaches may not work
as it is.
There are a lot of challenges which we
need to, we need to write some,
tweak certain rules or use a combination
of libraries or clean the data first so
that my library can detect the text in a
more efficient way.
and manner and so on. Okay,
so there are a lot of challenges when you
look at the real world scenario. Plus,
as somebody correctly said,
there could be language, mixed language.
Okay,
so code mixing could be there on a
particular text.
So there could be language specific,
there could be genre specific.
So even like there was one.
project which was extracting resume,
right, automatically. Even in the resume,
if you want to automatic information
extraction and do some analysis.
So for example,
HR person wants to find out like who are
the people who are working in this area
and what are their contact details
automatically because the resumes are in
different formats, right? Some may have.
photographs,
some may not have photographs,
some may be left aligned,
some may be right aligned.
Even within PDF,
you may have a lot of variety, right?
So layout is a problem and how do you
automatically extract?
So when you start doing these real world
problems, it starts getting challenging.
Plus website formatting,
web pages have their own challenges.
How do you extract the data from the web
scale data?
Okay, so again, there are challenges.
There is a lot of noise in the web scale.
There might be advertisement popping up
and so on.
So how do you extract this important
information from these web pages is also
a challenge. Okay, so there is a,
this is not an easy problem,
information extraction.
And it needs a lot of complex development
architecture for implementing these
systems. Okay,
so basically you want to 1st find and the
relevant parts of the text.
Then you need to give a proper
representation for this.
So you need to organize whether this is a.
the name of a place and so on.
And finally,
you may want to store it in a database or
a knowledge base or a vector data store
and so on. Okay,
so this is our goal of information to
extract this important key information,
automatically structured information from
the unstructured text.
So the information that you are
extracting could be like who did what
that person did, whom it did, when it did.
All this information you may want to
extract and not just extract these pieces
of information,
also find out the relations like this,
right? Like a triple, okay,
which is filled in the knowledge graphs.
which can be further used for further
processing of different applications.
Right now, again, there are challenges,
like for example,
you might need a low level info.
So this is now coming to the application.
So here you can see that today,
automatically from the emails,
you were calendar.
So I always have this challenge.
Somebody is calling me, say,
for being a chief guest or for.
giving,
delivering an expert session or maybe a
meeting with the faculty or meeting with
students. I always find this challenging.
I have to go back and look in my calendar.
Nothing comes offhand to me because I
don't know what is entered in my calendar.
I have to unfortunately tell everybody,
give me some time.
I'll look in my calendar.
figure out the time to have the meeting
and then schedule.
And it may so happen that I might miss
out, and which does happen, unfortunately.
So I call,
I just blame it as an absent-minded
professor. Actually,
because it doesn't trigger right at that
my time.
And so I have scheduled some meeting one
week later, and I don't remember it.
right?
So that can happen with everybody and
anybody.
So this automatic extraction will also
schedule like from your text,
it will send you a reminder,
it will create automatic event for you.
But for this, of course,
it needs to extract this low level
details.
Sometimes it may need to figure out the
date, date and.
calendar date as well. So, but yes,
today it is possible to do so. Okay.
So information extraction could be from
your web pages. So earlier,
so like when we did the semantic search
system,
we wanted to extract important pieces.
So for example,
which faculty is doing research in what
area.
and how many student requirement does
that faculty have, etc.
So if I want to extract the exact pieces
of information, again,
information extraction is useful.
So information extraction has almost
every NLP application today uses
information extraction as the first basic
step.
Okay, now coming to the, as I said,
named entity in particular.
So when we talk about named entity
recognition in particular,
first we need to find, okay, so yes,
is there a doubt?
Yeah.
No. Okay.
So first we need to find what are the
entities. So this is the find part, right?
So I need to find out these are the
entities. Now you can see here,
it's not that easy.
Somebody had talked about capital letters,
right?
So although this is a capital letter,
this is not a named entity, right?
So whereas this is a named entity,
so as I was telling about abbreviations.
Right,
so abbreviations may not be named
entities. So how do you capture that?
Again, this 2010, right? It's a number,
but it's a named entity, like the date,
right? So how do you classify this?
And sometimes by mistake,
I might write this Tony as small Tony,
like this.
Okay,
but still I need to figure out that this
is a named entity, right? So it's not,
so first very important subtask is
finding the entities. That is first task.
Secondly, as I said before,
we need to classify.
Now how do you say that this is a name of
a person,
this is a name of an organization,
this is a date, and so on.
Okay, so that is also you want to,
so that is your next task. Classify.
So first,
this color is indicating the type of the
entity. So this is person entity,
this is date, this is location,
and this is organization, right?
So you first need to find from this piece
of text.
what is the named entity,
and next you need to classify,
which is the type of the entity. Okay,
so now how do you do this?
We are going to look at the issues.
There are a lot of further issues also,
which we will talk about now.
We talked about issues in general for
information extraction.
Now we are going to talk about in
particular for named entity recognition.
What are the issues in particular for
named entity recognition?
Now I will talk about this tagging.
This is called as bio labeling,
which is a standard measure even today,
even in LLM,
when you are using the label data for LLM
for prediction,
for predicting the named entity,
today also they're using this.
Labeling is done by something called as
bio, which is between the entities.
So here it's a simple outside entity and
a named entity.
But today what they use is this other
type of, yeah, this one,
by IOB encoding is what is standard,
or they call it as bio encoding.
I'll touch upon this later.
We'll just skip this slide temporarily.
Now,
let's look at ambiguities or challenges
in particular with respect to named
entity recognition. Till now,
we talked about information extraction,
the challenges about the type of the data.
These are in general applicable for all
the information extraction tasks. Now,
we will focus on the challenges for
NER, named entity recognition. Now,
as you can see here, there are variations,
right?
So you can call the same person by
multiple. So I can have Professor Chetana,
Doctor Chetana, Chetana G. Chetana.
I mean, I can have multiple names, right?
So this is the task, how do you extract?
Secondly,
there are challenges like date versus
time. So this could be 19 dot dot,
so 745 or it's a year.
Then Washington is a name of a person as
well as a name of a location. How do you,
so you may extract it as a named entity,
but how do you decide whether it is a
location or a person?
Okay,
classifying the entities can be a very
big challenge.
May can be a name of a person,
name of a month. Tata,
you know that you have products of Tata,
Tata cars are there. Then you have,
of course, research foundation.
Then there are a lot of organizations
which are named. And of course,
you have Ratan Tata,
which is the name of a person.
Right? So it's a challenge.
How do you classify ambiguity in the
detection of the type of the named
entities? Plus,
there are other challenges like the
issues of style, structure, domain,
genre for the NER itself. So for example,
Birla Institute of Technology and so with
Spilani, right? Then you also have WILP.
Okay, so work integrated learning program,
how do you get all of these?
Plus there are of course abbreviations in
many of the places.
So how do you tell me more about,
so now here it is just telling the name.
Okay,
so how do you extract these entities?
Till what point?
So this whole thing is actually the name
of the department.
This whole thing is the name of the
university, right?
So that's another challenge that I might
extract this as a named entity,
this as a separate named entity,
but I want this whole thing to be
extracted as the name of the university,
right? So that's another challenge.
Till how long do I consider,
because you cannot have a fixed number
here.
of number of words and so on.
So that's another NER problem.
And this we already told you or discussed,
right?
There are also subtypes of named entities.
Okay, so subtypes also need to be defined.
How do you define the subtypes and so on?
So that is the,
these are some of the challenges.
Sorry about this formatting.
I did it last minute, but yeah,
I'll correct it later before uploading.
Anyway, so basically,
let me just show the approaches now.
I hope the NER concept,
the challenges of NER information
extraction is clear to all before we move
on to the approaches.
Ma'am, a small doubt.
Yes, please ask.
In IE pipeline, you have shown 5 stages.
Huh.
Yes.
I didn't understand that reference part,
ma'am, reference resolution.
Ah, sorry,
I actually did not explain that.
Thank you for letting me know that.
I forgot to explain that.
Okay, ma'am.
So the reference part is, so for example,
I say that Chetana is teaching
conversational AI in Bits Pilani.
She is also teaching NLP applications in
WLP.
Bitspilan, WILP.
Now WILP is referring to Bitspilani and
she is referring to Chetana.
So that is coreference.
So second sentence also,
there are these named entities which have
a relation with the first sentence.
So that is coreference.
So that is also a part of information
extraction.
Clear?
What's the event detection on there?
What is the?
4th one.
Event detection. Yeah,
so event is particularly suppose you have
like conference information.
When is this conference being going to
conducted? What date to what?
Let's take for our classes, right?
NLP application is 340 PM to 540 PM.
Conversational AI.
So that's a event that is occurring and
that's occurring say.
for 16 sessions, contact sessions.
So that's an event and it has a time.
So it is a special type of relation,
focusing on the time.
Okay.
Understood, ma'am. Yeah, yeah. Thank you.
Yeah,
so we will talk about all of these in the
further contact sessions. Today,
the focus is going to be on NEERADI.
Okay,
so now coming to the approaches of NER.
So first we will start with the simple
approach, which is rule based. Okay,
although people feel,
why am I teaching ML,
rule based neural network and all,
it is as you have now,
it come from Google itself.
Google is like one of the best top
companies and.
It has come from the expert.
They use all of these approaches.
It's not that people only use LLM and
Agent TKI in each and every industry
application. So therefore,
it is important to understand all of
these approaches. In fact,
BILS TM CRF was the most popular,
or rather is also currently at least 50%
of the organization do use these.
approaches. Okay,
so I will talk about all of these soon.
So,
rule-based is like you write manually
written linguistic rules or use some
regular expressions. As somebody said,
first letter,
capital or words beginning with Mr.
Doctor,
Professor are actually the person names.
Okay, or this format of date,
this is your regular expression, right?
So if this is the text that you have in
this format,
then it is a date type of entity. Okay,
or if you have a rupee or you have a
dollar or any of these symbols,
then it is indicating that it is a money.
Okay, so this is some example, Dr.
Abdul Kalam.
So here we see that first it is starting
with doctor. So it is a named entity,
which is a name of a person.
And then we also look for another rule,
which is like first letter capital of the
next word after doctor.
So this is indicating
that this is a,
because you may also have etc, full stop,
something like this, right?
So that's not a named entity or I don't
know,
I can't think of a good example here,
but there could be a case scenario where
you don't,
you have something which is coming from
here,
but next one is not say name of a movie
or something like that.
Okay, so or name of a series like Dr.
Philip. Okay,
so that may not be a name of a,
it's a name of a person also,
but it's also a name of a series, right?
So basically the advantages are zero
training, right? So the cost is 0 here.
You do not have any cost as such.
It is easy for small domains and it is
extremely interpretable.
That's the best part. It's explainable.
And explainability actually should have
the maximum weightage in the industry
because it's important to know why you
got a particular result, right? Otherwise,
if the system does anything.
randomly,
you do not know why that system is doing
it randomly.
So it's very important to understand the
explainability part,
and that is the best in rule-based. Okay.
Now coming to the second one,
which is ML based.
Now this is quite popularly used even
today.
So I will go a little more detail
compared to the rule based. Rule based,
I just have one slide, but let's say,
let's look at ML based approaches now.
Now coming to the ML based,
whenever we talk about whether it is ML,
DL or neural network, of course,
same as DL by the way. Okay,
so all of these approaches,
when you look at all of these approaches,
you need huge training data and the
entire output will entirely depend on
this training data.
So all of these approaches are called as
corpus based or training data based or
whatever.
I mean, basically,
they are data hungry approaches.
You need a lot of data for these
approaches. So first,
you need to collect the set of
representative training documents.
That is the first thing that you need to
do for your ML based approach. Now,
when we are talking about NER.
Now we are focusing only on named entity
recognition here.
So here you need to label each token for
its entity class.
And here is where that bio encoding comes
into picture. Okay,
so here what you need to do is you need
to have this kind of a label data where
it tells you, okay, this word is a person.
This word is O is indicating outside
context.
So whatever words are not named entities
in the training data are considered as O
words, outside context.
This is your person. Okay,
this is also person. This is outside,
outside, outside.
Now I will tell you about this B&
I also. This is.
more specialized labeling than simple IO
encoding.
IO will only tell whether it is an entity
or not an entity. Whereas in case of now,
why we need this B and I is because some
entities might span across 3 words, okay,
or two words.
So here this beginning of person is
indicating this is a individual entity.
And these two together, like B and I,
is another named entity.
So whenever you have a I coming after B,
that means it is following the beginning
of the person.
So this is another person name,
and this is one person name.
So this can be easily identified when you
use the IOB or bio.
It is both the terms are used.
Bio is just for acronym.
It's the same thing.
So you have a beginning,
you have an intermediate,
and you have outside.
OK,
so you need such kind of a label data for
ML or even in fact for transformer
everywhere you need that label data.
Okay, so that is required. Now,
because we are talking about ML-based
approach,
we also need to design the features,
because feature engineering is important.
That these features contribute to person
name,
these features contribute to organization
name,
these features need contribute to
location name. Okay,
and also you need to identify what are
the different entities.
classes that you're trying to identify,
whether you're only looking at person
names or you're looking at person names,
location name, organization name,
and so on. Okay,
so you need to have that label data first
for ML algorithms and you also need to
have it for the respective classes. Plus,
whenever we are talking about ML,
this is required for both.
It is required for...
ML, DL, neural network, agent,
transformer, everywhere. In addition,
for ML-based approach,
you also need feature engineering.
You need the proper features for each of
these classes.
So you either need to do a feature
engineering, tell key, okay,
this is the feature, this is the value,
and this is the class that needs to be
there in your training data.
Once you have this data,
now you are going to train the classifier
to predict the labels from the data.
So you are using this,
so you can use now like any
classification algorithm. You can use SVM,
you can use Naive Bayes classifier,
you can use decision tree, AdaBoost,
or even gradient boost,
any of these classification algorithms.
can be used for your NER problem,
named entity recognition. Okay,
so now here there are two things.
One is you're trying to classify the
entities. Okay,
so this is for classification,
finding what is the type of the entity.
Okay, for finding that whether there is a.
label data,
there is another ML classifier that needs
to be used. Okay,
so it's a very hard problem if you want
to do it using MLDL approach. Okay,
so you have to receive a set of testing
documents,
run the sequence model inference,
and label each token. Now,
If you want like this,
the combined entities,
then you must have those in your label
data. Only then in your test data,
you will be able to predict this as a
named entity, which is a person name.
If you do not have,
you will not be able to predict it.
That's another problem with machine
learning, right?
So you need to have the appropriate
labels in your.
text corpus,
training corpus to appropriately get for
your output. Okay,
so that's the machine learning approach.
So here what could be the features.
To decide,
can you tell me what could be the likely
features to decide what is the named
entity for machine learning?
Can you tell me, are you guys with me?
It's 420. I know it's end of day. Yes.
For a given name, is it?
For a given name,
is it a person or otherwise a person
You is.
Call Stack.
POS, part of speech tag. Yes, correct.
class or is it a post tag or otherwise an
adjective tag, something like that?
For stack, yes, that could be a feature,
then.
Or otherwise,
is it a noise or is it out of vocabulary
class? Something like that, ma'am.
Yes, so word itself can also be features.
If you remember, Ashish, Professor, Dr.
Ashish had told, right? So current word,
the previous word, the next word,
Yeah.
context words, part of speech tags, right?
All this can be your features, right?
Which can be used for...
Now you will need to use a sequence
learning.
This is a sequence learning problem.
By the way,
information extraction is a sequence
learning problem.
You give a sequence of input text and you
get a sequence of named entities.
Just like part of speech tagging,
it's a sequence learning problem.
So you can use your HMM,
hidden Markov models.
All these models can also be used.
your LSTM, every model,
whichever is appropriate for a sequence
learning problem, can sorry,
it can be used for this particular
problem,
which is a named entity recognition,
right? So these are some of the features.
So this is 1 paper from Stanford
University students.
So they came up with this simple.
features, right? So for medical field,
they identified if there is a colon or
these kinds of words like KOHRI or
whatever these words are,
they identified that these are medical
dogs. These kinds, if it has a colon,
then they identified that it is a movie
name or a place name and so on.
Okay, so certain features were identified,
even as somebody said, first letter,
capital, second letter, capital, dash,
that is indicating the name of,
so capitalization, length,
how much is the length. Okay,
so these kinds of,
or there are Greek letters,
there are internal punctuation,
one letter small, then letters,
capital letters. So this could be a DNA,
RNA, medical kind of.
vocabulary.
So some kinds of features were used and
then these were trained on this label
training data and for the test data you
identify among these entities, drug,
company, movie, place and person. Now,
of course,
as you can see for machine learning,
you need
Lot of things you need feature
engineering, you need the classes,
and of course it is also restricted to
those classes. So tomorrow,
if I have want to implement this
algorithm for another type of named
entities, I will not be able to do so.
I will again need a label data.
I will again need to train my model and
so on, right?
So that's of course a challenge,
but it is possible to do a named entity
recognition using the machine learning
algorithms if you have the label training
data.
And then you can use any of these
classification algorithms. As I told you,
you can train the classifiers.
I'll talk about these. You know, MEMM,
we had.
talked about it in our post tagging in
case of NLP codes,
conditional random fields, SVMs, HMM,
any of these can be used for getting the
NER.
Okay,
so of course you need human annotation
labeled data has to be there.
This feature extraction and IOB,
I told you this has to be there.
If you have this information from the
collection of the document,
something like this, this notation,
if it is already there with you,
you can then train your classifier and
get.
your named entity classifier automatic
NER system. Okay, so now again,
this can be, there is a challenge.
How do you label these entities?
So this is your label data, right?
So again, labels can be like this,
where you are labeling, okay,
this is a person entity,
which is together.
Okay, this is easier to identify,
but you could also label it as in this
manner. Okay,
so you could have a separate, sorry,
it's not shown here.
You could name it as this is labeled as a
named entity, which is organization,
or you could label it within the text
itself. Okay,
basically you need label data.
So you could also label it like this,
beginning of a person.
I wanted to show this slide actually.
So you could label it in this manner or
you could label it in this manner,
beginning of the person,
I person and so on. Okay,
but you need this kind of a label data.
Now, one challenge, as I told you,
for this ML-based approach is that you
develop a NER system for certain type of
entities. It may not be useful for, say,
another domain like biological.
The named entities may itself differ.
Forget about the content,
but also the named.
type of named entities like tissue.
These are very complex kind of named
entities, right,
which may not occur in a generic English
name, person, person name,
organization name, and so on.
So this requires further label data,
especially for this particular domain.
You also need special features.
The same features that you use for the
earlier model may not be applicable for
this. So it's a hard problem.
It's not that easy to implement the named
entity recognition system using any
approach, not just machine learning,
but other approaches also.
It's a hard problem.
Okay, so NER in this domain is difficult.
As I said, you might have a combination.
And plus,
so usually there are approaches where
knowledge graphs are often used for named
entity recognition.
Because in medical domain, as I told,
I had also used in my PhD,
Stanford University has a bio portal.
I know of that,
but I'm sure this must be true for many
domains, including legal and so on.
So there's a lot of dictionary or data
sets like knowledge graph,
which is available,
which is telling you the different named
entities in that domain along with the
relations.
So we can easily use the knowledge graph
themselves for extracting.
the named entities from the text.
That is also one of the most popularly
used approach for named entity
recognition or rather information
extraction in general. Okay,
so that can be one approach which is a
easier approach than doing feature
engineering and generating the label data.
But yes, you can also do.
this approach,
which is using the machine learning. Now,
other algorithms other than the
classification,
you can also use MEMM algorithms,
which are maximum entropy.
We have seen this MEMM algorithms for
part of speech tagging. We had seen this,
right? So given a set of text,
you want to label it with the part of
speech tags.
Now,
the same problem is here for named entity.
Given a piece of text,
you want to label it with the named
entities, right?
So you could have a bio encoding or you
could have like this encoding,
which is just the name of entity and
outside. Okay,
so or even in the gene scenario,
you may want to do
genetic, that's also sequence problem,
right?
So you can use now the MEM algorithm,
okay?
So typically the maximum entropy Markov
model,
this is based on the Markov model concept
only,
but we have seen in pause tagging also in
NLP that MEMM is a discriminative
classifier.
HMM was a generative classifier, right?
So in HMM, we use the probability.
So posterior probability was prior
multiplied by the likelihood. Here,
we look at it like a directly
classification problem.
We classify using features.
So here again, the classification,
you can see that it's the current word,
previous word, and so on.
All these can act like features.
You use any classification algorithm and
you do the tagging of the part of speech
tags. Okay, so this is a simple,
the same MEMM approach can be,
which was used for pause tagging.
is now used for the named entity tagger.
Okay,
now there are certain challenges here in
MEMM as well. If you're using, by the way,
what is the time?
Do you want to take a break? It's 430.
Can we complete this MEMM and then take a
break? Is it okay?
The.
In.
Yes, ma'am.
I know it's a bit long for you,
but can I just complete MEMM and then
take a break?
SHARMA.
Children?
Yes, ma'am.
Okay, let's just complete this, okay?
So let's talk about this.
Showman.
So basically in MEMM,
what are the challenges now?
Okay, so as I said before,
even though you may have the labeling
like this, that beginning of the person,
I person and so on,
now a question like this,
Ratan Tata Foundation. Okay,
now what happens is if you are using the
sequence model, how will it do?
It will go from left to right.
It will start labeling.
Each word, one by one. OK,
so it will label. OK, OK,
this is a beginning of a person.
Ratan is a beginning of a person. OK,
then it will see. OK, it will calculate.
So, what is it doing? A maximum,
even if you're using discriminative
classifier, it is a probability game,
right? It is finding the argmax.
probability of the maximum.
So among beginning of person,
beginning of organization,
beginning of place or some other things,
beginning of person is having the maximum
probability and therefore written word is
marked as BI.
This is 1 class that is identified for
this particular word.
Okay, then you will move to the next.
It's a sequential model, right?
So one word is done,
you will go to the next word,
try to predict its class.
So first word is Ratan,
which you have predicted as beginning of
the person.
Then you will predict the word Tata now.
Again, for Tata word,
you will find out whether in your
training corpus, in your label data,
Tata word has maximum probability for I
person, beginning person,
or is it an organization? Okay,
so based on that,
you will identify this as a I person.
Okay, now next word comes, foundation.
Okay, now here is the problem.
What happens is because you have selected
the maximum probability greedily.
At every point of time,
you may end up giving only foundation as
the beginning of organization,
so you may not correctly identify the
named entities. Ideally, what you want,
this is beginning of organization,
intermediate organization,
so the whole thing, Ratan Tata Foundation.
is actually the organization named entity.
Okay,
so instead of doing the greedy selection,
sometimes what they do is,
I'm not going into the details of this,
but sometimes they also select the top
three. If you remember,
we had discussed this in one of the
sessions,
that instead of greedily selecting the,
so like the temperature parameter instead
of.
selecting the max popular one,
you select the top two. Okay,
and then you go ahead and select the next
top two and so on. And then finally,
you come up with the max probability by
multiplying the individual probability.
So in that process,
you might probably come up with this
organization as the highest probability
when you take the combined probabilities.
Okay, so this MEMM inference time,
you can do it like that.
Instead of directly greedily selecting
one at a time,
you could select multiple and then select
the best one. Okay,
so that is the MEMM approach for named
entity. So this is what is explained.
So greedily, you start from left,
user classifier input.
Position to assign a label classifier
will depend on the this. OK,
so here there's no extra memory and very
easy to implement,
but we can commit errors. OK,
so this is what I told you.
This is for the greedy inference. OK,
so this,
but generally we don't go for a greedily
approach.
We use the beam search. Actually,
by mistake, I deleted that slide,
but we use beam search.
I'll just add it when I upload it. Okay,
so where you select,
instead of greedily selecting the best
sequence, you select the top two, top two.
So you will, here you will,
in this example,
I will select B of person as well as B of
organization.
and so on. OK, so that is your MEMM. OK,
so before moving on to the other
approaches, neural transformer, LLM,
and RAJAT based approach,
we'll take a break.
And I'll also show you the implementation.
I do have the implementation.
I'll show you that as well.
Let's take a very quick break.
Okay, should we continue?
Yes, ma'am.
Are you all back? Yes, let's continue.
Okay.
Yes, ma'am.
Okay, somebody has raised hand.
Do you have a doubt?
Or was it by mistake?
Kartikian, are you there?
But I'm not able to remove that one.
Still, I'm not able to.
I tried not able to remove.
Sorry, no.
Not able to do what?
Andre is OKOK.
Uhh.
I'm not.
Ah, okay, okay. Oh, yeah, fine, fine.
Okay.
Okay,
now I am not going to go into
mathematical details,
neither I will ask any mathematical
problems on conditional random fields.
I will let you know.
I'm still yet to think about it.
So I will let you know one session before
your end sem. And anyway,
Sorry, anyway, we will take a recap also.
So that time I'll tell you what kind of
problems you can expect for NSEM, etc.
But you should note this concepts, okay?
So that's why this MEMM and all,
I'm covering all these things.
So CRF is another commonly used,
so it's in line with.
MEMM itself.
So this is another sequence model,
conditional random fields.
This is actually, oh, I'm sorry.
If lights are not shared.
Uh-huh.
Yes.
Ohh.
For us, like the current content,
like the...
What do you mean by short forms?
So slides you want me to reduce it, is it?
Yeah, the reduce forms.
I will try.
I should get that much of time.
Becomes that.
I understand what you're trying to say to
take the prints for your final right in
Yeah.
Right.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
the consolidated.
So what I will try to do,
I should get time if my learning
facilitators are kind enough to help me.
I will take their help.
Okay.
So I will try to remove these.
Are you able to see the slides,
by the way?
Yes, yes, yes.
So I will try to remove these initial
ones, these content and all.
And is it okay?
And references and if there are any
images which I don't think are,
so I can remove those.
Yes, yes ma'am,
that would help and anything else if you
Yeah.
could help in there, yeah.
Yeah,
so I will try to remove these reference
Thanks.
things. Let me see, I should get time.
Let me see if AI can do it for me.
Yeah.
I'll try to do that. Like, I mean,
it's not a much big deal deleting this,
Yeah.
Okay.
but it takes time. That's all.
It's very easy job,
but it's time consuming, that's all.
And plus we have to do that watermarking.
That's another sometimes that because of
Yes.
that watermarking also,
some things become here and there.
So yeah,
it's not a easy thing for us also,
but yes.
I will try to do as much as possible.
Make your, you can also do one thing,
you can take relevant slides only.
You don't have to take all.
I know for you also there is some work.
So I don't know, can you from PDF?
Now, what happens, ma'am,
is by the time the watermark slides are
Huh.
Huh?
shared, it's actually late towards game,
so then at that point of time...
No, no, no, no, no.
This time we are doing it earlier.
Okay.
We are planning to do it.
When is your exam? I forgot the date.
September, September 5th.
A fifth supplement.
5th September, okay. Teachers Day, okay.
So, yeah. So,
Yes, yes.
He just did.
I will try my best to do it by 15th of
August,
16th of August as much as possible.
Yep, thanks.
Okay,
so at least two weeks you will get for.
I'll try my best to do that.
I actually need to prepare for last
session. So other sessions are ready.
I can do it right away.
Only the last session I need to prepare a
little bit. Let me see, otherwise I will,
no,
but it's better to do everything together.
I'll do it together only. Okay,
so I'll try my best to do that for you
Okay, thanks.
all. Okay, so, okay, coming back to this.
So basically,
this MEMM is again a discriminative
classifier.
So this is also conditional random fields
is on the same principles as hidden
Markov models.
And in terms of the MEMM also,
they are similar.
So basically you are computing the arg
max probability,
like just like the discriminative
classifiers, right?
So you are predicting the output or
conditional,
that's why it's called as conditional.
So conditioned on.
a certain parameter,
certain features and the input,
you are predicting the output.
So the named entity is based on certain
tokens,
certain features you are predicting on
the output. Okay,
so it's the same concept as the
discriminative classifier.
This formula also you will see it's
similar to your softmax function.
You are predicting.
predicting the probability E raised to
divided by some of the probabilities. OK,
so it's the same concept, not much.
So I'm not going into the details of it,
mathematics of it,
but this is also another algorithm in
machine learning for predicting the named
entities. OK, so you are the.
Training is slow.
The reason is because it is looking at
the previous words.
Whereas in this particular MEMM,
it does not look at the previous word for
producing the next word. Okay,
so that's the difference between the
conditional random fields and MEMM and
the HMM. HMM we are not covering.
MEMM and CRF. Okay,
now as I told you before,
the named entities, okay, vary.
So whenever you're doing the automatic
content extraction or named entity
extraction, etc., you may need NER.
So there are specialized NER extractors.
for legal domain.
There are specialized NER extractors even
when you're using transformers. Okay,
so there are a particular embedding
models also I saw interestingly for
different domains.
So you have a NER for legal,
NER for medical and so on.
So this is because the features can be
different for the different domains and
so on.
So that's why you have different NER
systems and even the gadgeteers, right?
So this is 1 algorithm where you are
looking for the,
so this is like a rule-based approach and
these are also features that are used.
So you might check whether that word is
present in the dictionary.
Gadget here is nothing but dictionary.
Okay, so for example, some genes, right,
might be very difficult to predict using
the machine learning classifier.
So you might have some inbuilt gadget
here or a dictionary from which you can
do that. Okay,
so these are just some example features
that are shown for.
this particular feature based NER system
which is using CRF for AMIN or any
classification algorithm.
This is just an example. Okay,
so this I already told you about the
tagging bio label data.
Now this is also important for even if
you go for.
neural models or your transformers,
everywhere you will see that the bio,
this same thing is used.
Everywhere this is used.
Whatever model you use,
whether you use LSTM,
whether you use machine learning,
everywhere this label data is always in
terms of bio tagging. Okay,
now this bio is also begin in and out.
So I already told you, right?
So begin of a person in.
person.
That means together this is 1 named
entity.
The other thing tagging that variant that
people do use in many of the transformer
libraries as well as other libraries is
this particular by BILOU.
That is just the further. So for example,
if some tokens you might have.
you want to indicate what is the last
word also. So for example,
here it is showing intermediate,
but I cannot infer whether the entity is
ending here.
I need to check the next word.
But if I have this kind of a tagging with
L,
I can immediately know that the starting
part and the ending part.
and I can figure out what is the total
span of that entity. Plus, in addition,
if you add this single unit token,
immediately I can know that I don't need
to figure out the next words. Okay,
so these are just the optimized.
So this is like if your data is tagged
well, you are going to get a better out.
That's all. So this is just a variant.
But anyway,
whether it is a transformer or any
approach, you have to do this tagging.
And typically this bio tagging is
commonly used. OK,
so even benchmark data sets for NER,
whatever you have,
they're always tagged with this bio
tagging. So a lot of such.
benchmark data sets do exist.
Now coming to the next approach.
So we saw now we have seen these by LSTM,
no, sorry,
we have seen the ML based approach and
the rule based.
Now we are going to look at the neural
based approaches,
then the transformers LLM will also see
using RAJ.
how to do the NER and we'll touch upon
the agent tech. Okay,
so I have not included in detail slides
on these. The reason being,
we are not going into the maths of that,
right? Because transformers,
we have time and again covered in various
courses in MTech, AIMLCZG.
So here I'm going to focus on use or
application of these different algorithms
for named entity recognition. Okay,
so I'm basically that saves you also from
the exam trouble.
Otherwise you will have to compute
mathematically the forward algorithm back
propagation and find out these entities,
right?
So, but the idea is same.
So here you can see this is a bi-LSTM
model. Okay,
because you are computing from left to
right dependencies as well as right to
left dependencies. Therefore,
this is a bi-LSTM.
And majority of the applications,
if you see, they will be using bi-LSTM.
And here actually you can use encoder
only architecture for any R problem.
BERT is sufficient. OK,
so any models of BERT are distilled BERT,
small BERT models are also good enough
for this named entity recognition. OK,
so basically what you're doing is given
this input of text, OK, you are trying to.
get these outputs.
These are nothing but the named entities,
right?
So it is identifying that Barack Obama is
a name of a person.
It is identifying that this is a location.
United States is a location. Okay.
Now you may also want to tag the
relations and so on.
That is not done here.
Here we are focusing the by LSTM model
only for the NER problem and we are
looking at person, location, organization,
or some specific types of named entities.
Okay, of course, as in the earlier case,
what you saw,
you need a label data like this.
This data should be there.
Now, as I said,
there are a lot of benchmark data sets
which you can use,
or you can create your own data sets
manually. There are, again,
a lot of tools which create like ragas
and all of these,
which create automatically the data sets
for you as well.
Or you can use the small language models,
you can train it on a certain data.
To create more such tuples of label data.
OK, so basically,
once you have that label data,
you can easily predict these using the
BI-LSTM architecture encoder only
architecture. You can given this input,
of course,
these weights will be trained end to end.
Again, your.
because you're using the BI-LSTM,
you do not need any feature engineering.
That's the advantage of these neural
networks and deep learning approach.
You don't need any features as such. Okay?
And bidirectional, so you have to get,
you get the signals from both ends.
So this also improves the accuracy.
So because as I told you,
the example of Ratan Tata Foundation,
right?
So if you look from left to right,
as well as right to left,
you can also have this foundation word
when you are predicting the tag for Ratan
and Tata, right?
Because you are looking now right to left,
foundation word is already seen in after
this. So immediately you can figure out,
okay, these are organization.
and not the name of a person. Okay,
so that's the advantage of by LSTM and
that's why by LSTM is used in the named
entity recognition.
Now, in addition,
the conditional random fields, yes.
I have a question. A question there. Ohh,
go ahead. I will ask you.
Map.
Yes.
Yeah, now left to right is sufficient now.
Why do we need both?
So that is what I'm saying now.
So if there is a ambiguity,
left to right is going to help you to
know, okay, okay, Obama, it is continuous.
But as I said, this example, right,
foundation.
right? When there is an ambiguity,
this could be Ratan Tata,
could be name of a person,
and it also could be name of an
organization.
So if you look at this foundation word,
this is easier for me to figure out, okay,
this is not a person,
but this is a organization.
That's why write to light.
And encoder side,
because anyway you have the entire text.
Right?
So whenever you have the entire test text,
it is always a good idea to use
bidirectional so that you can capture the
context from this as well as from right
as well as from left.
No more question.
Okay, yes.
Yeah,
so now you referred to the encoder only
model here because we are referring to
the mask language modeling here as it is
Right.
not there in the decoders,
hence it's not applicable for decoder.
Is that the right understanding?
Yes,
and also you are not producing a new
Okay.
output here.
You are tagging the input itself.
So in machine translation,
you have to produce the new output, right?
Mm.
You have to generate a new output.
Here there is no generation.
Yes.
You are just tagging. That's why.
Ohh, OK. Thanks.
Clear? Okay,
any more doubts before we move on to the
further?
Okay,
now this Bi-LSTM CRF is a variation of
Bi-LSTM, which is actually similar.
Additionally, you are adding this CRF,
conditional random field model,
at the output side after the Bi-LSTM.
This is to further improve. So
CRF is again, unlike CRF only.
So basically, instead of using only CRF,
now you are combining these by LSTM with
CRF to improve the performance.
So basically what happens is the CRF is
combining,
concatenating the context and putting a
condition.
that only if the left hand side is this,
then the right hand side is having this
entity. Okay,
so because of this conditioning of the
conditional random fields in the,
so in the normal by LSTM scenario,
it is only going to look at the softmax,
and sorry,
it is only going to look at the softmax.
max and predict this. Okay,
coming from both the sides also,
it is only looking at the soft max.
It is not checking whether the output of
this is not dependent on this.
So there's no condition which is provided
in by LSTM.
Whereas when we talk about by LSTM CRF,
the output is conditioned on the previous
output.
This is conditioned on this. Okay,
so that's the,
I'm not going into the maths part as I
said before, but this is the,
this is also looking at the,
so this output is conditioned like this
formula is used.
Okay,
so it is conditioned on the previous
output. Okay,
so it's like you are additionally also
looking at the previous.
So when you are predicting this,
you are also looking at the what is the
tag that is predicted before.
You are not only looking at left and
right words,
but you are also looking at the tags.
That improves the accuracy,
for especially when you have the
concatenated kind of words.
This is very useful, like bits, OK,
where you have multiple words,
so when you look at the previous words.
tag,
it helps to disambiguate further and give
you a better tagging or better NER
classification. That's why this is used.
Again, as I said before,
I am not going into the maths part of it.
I'm just showing you the architecture of
it. Okay, so similarly, as I said,
encoder only. So BERT,
this is transformers.
So you are of course,
I don't need to use the attention
mechanism.
When I talk about neural models by LSTM,
CRF here, I am not looking at,
there's no attention mechanism here.
It is just a simple LSTM network which is
used in both the direction.
I am not talking about the attention
scores at all when I talk about this by
LSTM model. Whereas with transformer,
the best part is the attention mechanism,
right, which was not there earlier.
So here it has that all these other
blocks that we have, right?
Multi-headed attention,
feed forward network,
so transformer will have all those blocks
which was not there,
so multi-headed attention. OK.
So,
the attention scores will be calculated
and so on. Again,
it is using encoder only architecture,
encoder representation. So, BORT is used.
OK,
but the difference between by LSTM CRF
and BORT is you are now using this
attention scores,
which was not there earlier.
So how are these attention scores going
to help you? Can you tell me?
What is the role of attention in NER,
named entity recognition?
Why can't you use by LSTM itself?
Why do we need transformers?
Can you tell me why do we need
transformers for NER?
Can anybody tell me?
So, uh,
they are better at capturing the context.
Range, Long Range.
From long-range dependency context,
long-range dependency.
Context.
Long range, yes.
So can you give me example or can you
tell me why do you need long range
dependency in NER?
For large paragraphs.
Just large paragraphs, large sentences.
Okay,
but still it can be within a sentence,
right? Seven words it can capture.
Okay, you are somewhat correct.
There is a large dependency that is being
Need to maintain.
captured, but yeah, somebody was saying,
please tell.
Now is it code reference?
Yes.
And.
Ma'am, context your relationship.
Yeah, but why?
Pop.
relationship, yes, correct.
So even for core reference resolution,
yes,
context is needed for multiple things for
relations also,
you need for even for core reference
resolution.
And I talked about core reference, right?
So I might say that Chetana is teaching
in bits, Pilani, she has done PhD, etc,
etc. And then somewhere.
I also have this reference that she's
teaching NLP applications. Okay,
and somewhere I've talked about that she
is working in Bits Pilani. Now,
the relation that in Bits Pilani she's
teaching is automatically derived because
of this long-term dependency, right?
So some kind of complex relations can be
derived because of these.
relation because of these long-term
tracking of context that you can keep
because of the attention score.
So transformer will be able to capture
better context as correctly said by all
of you and it will be able to give me
better named entities also. Therefore,
transformers are used popularly.
for your named entity recognition. Okay,
so there are a lot of transformer models
which are openly available. Again,
a lot of LLM models, okay, are also used.
So what is the difference?
Is it same?
LLM and transformer.
And as a generation,
no madam generator decoder.
Yes,
so what is the difference between LLM
models like GPT and transformer?
What is the difference?
Is generative AI right? LLMs.
From transformer is the underlying
architecture that LLMs are using.
Yes, but what do you mean by that?
decoder and encoder decoder architecture.
Encoder, decoder.
Back to basics. Yes,
so encoder decoder is not there in the
Yeah, GPT.
That's so well.
LAL models.
LLM uses transformers.
GPT.
Only decoder.
EPT is decoder based.
Yes, yes.
GPT's decoder run.
Yeah, transformer is in the architecture.
The cross-attention versus...
Oh?
CLM and sequence to sequence.
One second, one second, decoder is LLM.
LLM doesn't use encoder.
Mum, LLM.
Yeah.
The thing is, with this ChatGPT,
it is a decoder architecture.
Yeah.
And transformers are what LLMs use.
LLMs use the transformers.
NC.
Internet.
So there could be different kinds of like
architecture of LLM in KONDAVEETI.
Okay.
On application when application.
Mom, stateless and stateful, mom.
LLMs are stateless.
Okay.
Stateless. What is stateless?
Yeah.
For example,
you take a conversational concept of LLM
I.
and transformer, sorry, not transformer,
agentic thing, yeah, where this.
It is.
On transformer is basically a neural
underlying neural network architecture,
but LLM is the application of that
architecture.
Yes.
Okay, you are somewhat closer. Yes,
you are right.
So it is like an architecture, right?
Transformer is like your LSTM
architecture.
All these are neural network,
different architecture.
So transformer is also one such neural
network architecture,
which involves attention mechanism.
Now the number of layers, et cetera,
is different.
It will vary from application to
application and model to model.
But that's the basic architectural level
concept, right?
So you don't have transformer like one,
transformer 2 like that, right?
So it's a architecture.
But whereas you have GPT, Claude,
these are your language models which are
pre-trained models and they are trained
using the transformer architecture on
certain data set for.
like predicting the next tokens, right?
So large language models are internally
using the transformers only, right?
But they are ready,
these are pre-trained models on the web
scale data or some training data for
producing the next tokens.
And because they are generative models,
because they are generating,
you can use for any kind of generation.
including the generation of a named
entity recognition tag, right?
MIDHUN.
So advantages, of course, yes.
Yeah,
like bot and already also those are
trained models,
but those are small scale model grade.
Yes.
Encoder models, yes, yes, correct.
They're encoder only models, right?
Yeah.
And generally the GPT and all are decoder
only models.
RAHATE?
So language modeling is a concept which
is implemented using these GPT, Claude,
and so on.
So it is the use of language modeling is
predicting the next set of tokens given
the previous set of tokens.
So you can do language modeling not only
by transformers,
you can do using n-gram language models
also, right?
So you can predict the next set of tokens
using statistical and gram language
models,
or you can predict the next set of tokens
using transformer models.
So language modeling can be done by both
the techniques, right? So it's a concept.
You are producing a set of tokens.
So what is a language model?
It is modeling the language.
That means it is predicting the next set
of tokens given a set of tokens, right?
So that's like a concept.
And transformer is an architecture which
is used for producing these next set of
tokens given the previous set of tokens
based on your training data.
So generally,
large language models are the pre-trained
language models using different
transformer architectures.
So they could be, as I said,
using statistical also. Okay,
so language model need not always be
based on the transformer architecture.
Clear?
Did I confuse you or did I bring some
clarity in your mind?
Yes.
No more.
Clear or confusing?
Then, can you explain again?
You said that language models need not
always be based on transformer. How is it?
Yes, yes,
because we have studied in NLP language
modeling can also be done using
statistical and gram language modeling.
RAHATE?
Okay, okay.
So today we use large language models,
always we interpret them using the
transformer architecture.
But the concept of language modeling,
okay,
is predicting the next set of tokens or
words given the previous set of tokens.
How you do it?
is generally like today,
it is becoming anonymous, synonymous.
We are calling LLM because most of the
LLM today, large,
the word large refers to transformers and
huge architectures because that gives you
the ability to produce large amount of
text.
But you can also do language modeling
using n-gram, right?
We have studied that using the
probability,
predict the next word given the previous
words.
So that is also one way of doing the
language modeling. So language modeling,
you need not always do it using
transformer.
Right? So it's a kind of,
you can say it as an application also,
if you can call it as an application,
but it's not an architecture.
Transformer is a neural network
architecture like LSTM.
All of these are architectures, right?
Feedforward network.
These are all architectures.
Clear.
Yes, ma'am. Thank you.
Okay,
so you can use these pre-trained language
models.
They can be large language models or
small language models for doing the named
entity recognition. Okay,
so you can use the existing models
themselves and send you your text and
tell them to do the named entity.
It will identify the name, place, file.
organization,
everything it will do because it is
pre-trained on a huge corpus.
So one of the tasks that it has been
trained on is also named entity
recognition. Therefore,
it is able to predict the named entities.
Now, of course,
there is a problem of hallucination.
And most of these language models cannot
be used for domain specific applications
like legal domain.
So that's why you have NER models
specifically designed for legal,
so there's a legal board model and so on.
Okay,
so most of these models need to be
fine-tuned for the applications.
You cannot use them as it is for your
application. And of course,
the cost is very, very high.
for these models.
So generally people will not use these
model in the real world production
environment.
People will not use these models for
named entity recognition. Okay, but yes,
you can use it. You can also use RAJ NER,
which is.
So the advantage of RAJ NER is you have
in your knowledge base, knowledge graph,
all the named entities. So for example,
in BITS Pilani,
what I do is I store this information.
Okay, these are the faculty names,
these are the courses names,
these are the topics within these courses.
And these are the programs that we have.
And all of these named entities,
I'm storing it in a knowledge graph. Okay,
so during the retrieval time,
I can immediately get the named entity
because I've stored them in my data store,
right?
So it's easier to get it using the
knowledge graph because I've stored all
of these diseases.
Whereas if I have to show,
send this to a generic LLM model,
the LLM model may not be figured out that
Chetana is teaching this course and so on,
right? So that information every semester,
of course, now if I just search,
sometimes it may just end up showing me
some courses which I teach,
but not always.
It will not show that this semester in
NSP 4,
in this October batch,
I'm teaching this course and so on.
That information will be there in my
local knowledge base,
which my RAJ will be able to exactly
extract.
Same is true for the other domains like
medical domain, legal domain, and so on.
Okay, to identify rare diseases, drugs,
procedures.
which the standard LLM cannot do.
So if you augment it with RAJ,
you might get a better output.
So RAJ is useful in even in the NER
scenario. Okay. Now, of course,
if you go for the agent tick, okay,
you can also use agents for doing the NER,
but it's an overkill.
Right, so, like that day,
even Doctor Rush,
I also give you these examples,
like going to market,
you don't take a particular rocket, right?
So, or you don't take a helicopter,
so the same manner, typically,
agentic workflows are not used for any
are in particular.
but they can be used for general
extraction. Okay,
so for contract analysis,
hospital documentation,
these places sometimes even for
scientific literature,
they do use agentic workflows,
but it's an overkill.
So although it can be used effectively,
it will give you good accuracy, but.
Generally people go for a maximum LLM and
NER using RAC. Okay, so sorry,
I don't know what TS.
Ma'am, in the rack,
who is like extracting the entities?
You said that we are storing the entities,
but where are we? I mean,
Yes.
who is extracting the any named entities?
So yes, let me tell you,
just give me a second now,
Yeah.
I just formatting this, yes. Yeah,
so in this particular situation,
we are having, so let me take an example.
OK, let's take the bits web pages.
Okay, so you have bits web pages. Okay,
now you have created a rag on bits pages.
Okay, let's take a concrete example.
Let's say Chetana.
OK,
and let's take course as NLP Applications.
OK,
so now in my rack I have stored this
information.
As a graph,
suppose this is your faculty and this is
your course name.
Okay,
so I've stored this in my embedding or
whatever graph as a graph I've stored.
And I've also stored the relation that
teaches an NLP application.
OK, sorry for this pen.
I hope you can read. OK,
so teachers and this is suppose your
course.
Okay, so all this is there in my rack.
Okay, now in the users prompt, okay,
I'm developing say a conversational AI
application for my bits,
particular bits website.
I want to know who is teaching which
course. Okay, so I ask the question,
who is teaching?
NLP application.
Or let us say that I want to find out
what is the type of named entity in my
text that I give. Okay,
so this is a named entity.
How will I know? By looking at the rag.
So I'll do a comparison of my input
prompt text with my rag embeddings,
retrieve the topic.
Okay,
and suppose I will get this NLP
application matching,
and I will get that this is the named
entity which is course, so I can get this.
So, this is for a NER problem, right? So,
given an unstructured text from my RAJ,
I can exactly retrieve what is the named
entity in my input.
Next.
So it is for that.
So I my test corpus could be anything,
right?
So I will extract for my test corpus what
is the named entity using my bits corpus.
So here I may give another kind of a
paragraph which may not have NLP
applications, but Chetana see.
Like so here it will identify K OK,
Chetana is a bits factor.
Clear.
OK, yes.
So, from the knowledge graph,
it is identifying the named entities.
Clear?
Yes, ma'am.
Okay.
So coming to the actual real world,
so I actually gave this.
So whether a rule based trans or how is
it used? Okay, so as I said,
suppose for some fixed kind of a thing
like pan card numbers, other card,
where you have a fixed kind of a REGE X,
regular expressions or invoice numbers or
date.
Right,
so typically rules are used using REGE X
for many of the named entity recognition
applications. Okay,
so even in the real world today,
so for example,
somebody asked you to develop a NER
application, say, for example,
you have a company which is working,
suppose, for example.
in finance domain, okay,
or banking sector.
So banking will have a PANDIT card,
Aadhaar card, maybe account number, right?
So suppose a form is given,
a form is submitted by some customer
asking for some information related to
the banking details or maybe the account
statement and so on.
And you want to automatically extract
some fields of information from this.
for storing it or doing some analysis in
your finance and so on. Okay, so you can,
so you want to do a named entity
recognition system for this kind of a,
so a submitted form,
whatever user submits.
Suppose whenever I want to open an
account,
I may give a handwritten or OCR some form
details and automatically you want to
extract.
So you may write first some rules to
extract this basic information.
So you don't have to do processing of
entire text in this document.
This is already taken care. Okay,
now next you may use for transformers,
may be used for entity,
which are the entities within this
particular text.
Then you may use the LLMs to detect the
type of the entities.
Okay,
then you may ensure use the rack to do
the ground check,
ensure that in your domain,
whatever entities have been extracted by
the transformers and LLM,
are they valid or not?
So rack can be used for grounding. Okay,
and then further you can use agentic
workflows further to
verify the customer information,
whether that should be shown.
So in the workflow,
you can have all of these steps.
for named entity recognition.
So that is what I wanted to stress,
that it is not that for every little
problem, everything you use,
the complete LLMs or agent tick and so on.
Even agent tick within themselves will be
using the NER to do the workflows and all.
OK,
so that's the point I wanted to stress.
OK, interestingly,
there are also ensemble NERs. OK,
so this is also very popularly used.
So they do use a combination.
So dictionary based NER will give certain
outputs, CRF will give certain output.
Spacey also has a.
most popular NER models. They, of course,
internally today use transformers.
Earlier they used to use the BILSTMCRF
models.
So you also have these kinds of ensemble
which you can use and then you can decide
the best kind of do the maximum voting
just like classification.
for finding the best NER.
That is also commonly implemented. Okay,
so coming to the last topic,
which is evaluation. What is the time?
Do we have time? I'm just checking.
And implementation. Okay, 10 minutes,
great. 20 minutes, yes.
By 20.
Sentiments.
Yeah.
So I can also show the implementation.
Do you want me to show the implementation
1st and then go to the evaluation?
I can do either ways. Let me know.
Should I show you the implementation
first?
Yes, ma'am.
By the way, assignment is not uploaded.
I should have done it a little earlier.
Yeah.
Fine. We will do it on 30th.
One more thing I wanted to tell about
assignments is I will let me just go to
this assignments.
Just give me a second before I forget.
I wanted to tell that.
Just give me a second.
So there is something called as situated
learning.
Did I discuss this with you earlier?
No, ma'am.
No, ma'am,
you said post-exam we will discuss here.
Did I? No, OK, OK.
You have been calling last time.
No, no.
Yes, ma'am, that's fine, Shelly. Yes,
ma'am. Before that, ma'am, assignment one,
You said it will be there but not the
context, mom.
we did not see marks.
For a 10 million.
What?
Assignment one.
For assignment one,
it is not a did not get math for
It's.
assignment one.
Oh, is it not done?
Because most of my LF told me they have
The.
completed evaluation.
No, no, but still, we are ready.
Even we didn't get the grades.
Yeah.
Oh, okay,
because last week when you told me,
immediately I told all my learning
facilitators and most of them had
completed long back.
No, man.
Only few were left.
I think we are among them.
Could be, could be.
You must be among them, maybe.
Hey.
I'll just remind only one of the learning
facilitators had not completed and I had
requested to complete it before this
weekend. Okay, let me just confirm it.
But yes, it is done by most of the
learning facilitators. Anyway,
I will check if at all something is
pending. Okay,
now coming to situated learning.
So what you have for assignment 2 is
there is this situated learning
evaluation component that you are going
to have. It is going to be like a quiz.
So what I mean by that,
let me just show you.
It will be opened on 30th July,
but let me just give a background.
I will also put an announcement regarding,
I'm just trying to search for that.
Just give me a second. Yeah.
Okay,
so this will be open on 30th of July,
but it's a quiz which has to be given
individually. Okay,
so you need to give this quiz all of you,
although your second assignment is going
to be a group assignment of 10 percentage
weightage,
exactly like your assignment one.
Of course, the topics will be different,
but it is going to be a programming
assignment. In addition,
there is this 5 percentage weightage that
is given to the situated learning part.
Now, what is this situated learning? So,
you will,
I'm just showing you these questions. So,
these questions...
Sorry.
Just give me a second.
Okay,
so here you will have these questions
which are like non-technical questions.
Okay,
so these questions are like organization
name, domain, your job role, etc.
So which you need to fill in individually
by each of you.
And some of the questions would be like
whether.
This particular course, let me,
I don't know why I'm not going.
Let me just show you. Just for example,
I wanted to show you,
but I don't know why I'm not able to go
to the next questions.
So it's a kind of feedback,
feedback on the course.
Just give me a second. Yes,
kind of feedback,
but not exactly the kind of feedback on
teaching.
But the kind of feedback like whether yes,
this course basically,
Subject.
is it relevant in your, so for example,
do you use these concepts in your job?
S.
Okay.
Where do you use? Okay, can you apply it?
Or do you, does your organization?
work on problems related to this
particular course. Okay,
these kinds of questions.
So there is a 5 percentage weightage.
So I will insist that please answer it
individually even though you may do the
assignment 2 in a group.
This has to be individually answered.
Okay,
and please give proper answers because
this will help also for me to understand
that whatever I'm teaching,
is it relevant in your workplace?
How is it relevant?
How can I make it better?
And these kinds of things. Okay,
so that is the purpose.
So the name situated learning is.
whatever learning that you're doing in
this course is useful in your particular
situation or your particular project,
your particular organization and so on.
Okay, so that is purpose of this.
So there is a 5 percentage weightage.
This also will be opened along with your
second assignment.
which is 30th of July to 15th of August.
Please meet the deadlines because I have
to submit the grading. Okay,
within a week's time,
it is going to be really tough.
I think I should have done it a little
earlier, but anyway,
so please complete your assignments
within time. Okay.
and also this situated learning form,
which has to be done individually. Okay,
so I just wanted to stress on that.
So that is 5 percentage weightage and 10%
is for your programming assignment. Okay,
so anyway,
I will put a detailed assignment
announcement regarding the same.
But I just wanted to tell you that, okay?
Now, coming to the implementation,
so there might be an implementation
assignment on named entity recognition,
assignment on relation extraction,
assignment on temporal event extraction,
assignment on index machine translation.
statistical machine translation,
all these concepts that you have covered.
Also, maybe something on privacy,
on ethics, implementing the guardrails.
These kinds of applications will be asked
in your assignment too for implementation.
It will be again a group assignment
similar to your assignment one.
Okay, now, anyway,
I'm going to upload and I have been
uploading the code in your e-learn on
regular basis,
which will definitely help you with your
assignments.
And actually programming is not such a
difficult task,
but thinking through the problem,
whether for this problem,
how will I go about it from start to end?
and so on, including the evaluations.
So let me just show you the
implementation.
So this is a code using spacey.
So as that day also, Dr.
Ashish told you the same thing, right?
Spacey and NLP are very popularly used
libraries.
For any so here this we are using the
spacey.
So this is the library,
this is open source and it does not even
consume resources. It is very fast. Okay,
on local CPUs also you can use it.
Then Beautiful Soup is a library for
cleaning the text. Okay,
so we are using the English,
so that's why EN core.
is used. Now, we are going to use the,
this is just for,
so here this visualization I'll show you
later, but this is a sentence.
Apple is looking at buying UK startup for
dollar 1 billion.
So here you can see that Apple is kind of
an ambiguous word, but.
it is able to figure out that this is our
organization. Okay,
so this zero and five is the location.
So from the 0th character to the 5th
character is the organization entity.
From 27th of character to 31.
So Spacey is also giving you the exact
positions of the entities.
So it is identifying the entity first.
It is giving the position and it is also
giving you the type of entity. Okay,
so it is automatically doing that.
And for visualization,
you can use this library,
which is displacing.
This is just to show you,
this is just a fancier form of this,
whatever I showed you here.
Okay,
so it's highlighting and it is labeling
what is the type of entity. Okay,
so here you can see that Apple is
organization,
UK is a geopolitical entity and dollar 1
billion is the money. Okay,
so it is able to automatically identify
that, right?
So you can also see the other entities
for a longer text,
other entities other than what you saw
here. So this is a text,
even for a longer text,
it is able to correctly identify the
entities. Okay, so that is interesting.
It is not just for one.
So it is taking into consideration the
context also. Okay, so this is 1 code.
Very simple code using spacey to find the
named entity.
You can do it from the web pages also.
Beautiful soup is just to clean the tags
and get it into the text so that it can
be easily figured out what are the
entities. Okay,
so here you can see this is again using
displacey.
for finding out the entities in the text.
Okay,
so this is an example of the code which
is using spacey.
It's pretty simple to implement,
not very difficult.
You can also try out yourself.
It's fast also. Okay,
now the question here in the case of
spacey,
you are using the ready-made spacey
library.
for named entity recognition. Now,
what if you want to do it for your own
implementation? Will this work?
Any idea?
Not necessarily.
Yeah,
because the entities that Spacey has may
not have the entities that you want to do.
Suppose, for example, bio domain,
as I gave you, even for bits Pilani,
right? Specific.
So I don't know whether it will figure
out. Probably it may. I don't know.
Let me parallelly try. OK, just to.
Simple.
Is it a rule-based library or it is also
okay?
No, no,
it is using transformers and it is it is
combination. They have not disclosed it.
Maybe you can figure out,
Okay.
you can see how does the spacey library
implement named entity.
I think they're using a combination of
rule based, just like what I told you,
right?
It's probably using for UK,
probably it's using dictionary lookup and
for the other probably it's using a
combination of transformers and maybe rag
combination of that as well.
You will have to check off. Okay,
but it's definitely using transformer.
I just wanted to try whether it is able
to.
Maybe we can try it out.
I don't know whether it will work.
We can try it out in parallel.
But my point is that it may not be able
to recognize the entity because, sorry,
I did not, anyway.
So basically a point is,
I'm not sure whether it will be able to
figure out these themed entities.
The reason being the Chetana or NLP word,
okay, NLP is not defined, okay, sorry,
because this was not running.
So let me try again.
Oh, nice. It's able to figure out, right?
Chetana and this.
We can drive faculty it was not,
I don't know, maybe let me see NLP.
Applications just for fun.
Okay, see, it is organization.
It is identifying as organization,
which is incorrect, right?
So here we want it as a course name.
So the point that I'm trying to tell you
is that the inbuilt models of spaCy and
the other ones may not be used as it is
for the real world applications.
You may need to customize it.
Okay, so you can,
so this is one of the methods of
customizing where you can use it using
NLP.
You can give your own perceptron taggers,
you can give your own data set,
sentence tokenization.
This is one of the simple techniques
using NLP. You can do from scratch.
labeling of whatever labels you want,
or you can use it using spaCy.
The second technique that you can use is
customizing the transformers.
So you can fine tune the existing BERT
model for named entity recognition using
your own data set. Now,
as soon as I start using the transformers
BERT model and so on,
I need to use GPUs for fine tuning
because fine tuning means what?
You are retraining the model on your data
set. So for that,
definitely you are going to need
resources, right?
So here we are retraining the existing
BERT model for named entity recognition
of your own data set.
So you can use that also.
So you can configure the data set that
you want. You can again, so here again,
you need the, as I told you,
you need that bio-encoded data.
So all this location,
this data set has to be,
this particular data set has to be
labeled with this bio-encoding.
And then you can fine tune it on your
existing model for this particular data
set and then use it for the new test,
your own data set. So,
but this will require a lot of things
like fine tuning will need the hyper
parameter tuning.
You will need to tune the entire model,
create the word embeddings for the new
test data.
And do all these steps right,
but you can do the fine tuning of the
existing models,
and then you can evaluate whether the
fine tuning model is giving you good
results and so on. OK,
so this is for that fine tuning can be
done. OK,
so you can do the NER by the existing
libraries or...
you can do the fine tuning of the NER
models which are there. There are also,
if you go to Hugging Face,
you will find there are, let me just,
instead of Hugging Face,
I'll just call it as NER for legal, okay?
I had seen that there are legal board
options also.
Okay,
so somewhere I had seen that legal NER.
Okay,
so here you can see for legal domain,
there are special NER systems that are
developed. Similarly,
there is for medical domain,
finance domain,
there are data sets also you can see,
right? So this is interesting.
So you can use those also if you want to
do it. And in the hugging phase also,
you will find lots such.
lot of such data sets which you can use
for respective domains. Okay,
so this is just to give you an idea if
you want to use it for your own
applications. Okay,
so that is about the NER implementation.
We have 4 minutes. It's 536.
I hope you have understood the code.
Let me just go to the evaluation or do
you want me to cover it in the next
session?
I'm okay with anything. Okay, sure,
I understand. Yeah, yeah, I know, I know.
Next, next session, ma'am.
Next session.
Yeah.
What?
Hats off to you for I know, I know.
Morning to evening,
Stan end of day.
four sessions you are attending, right?
Eight hours.
Yes, ma'am.
Great, great. Nice, nice. Appreciate.
Okay, so we'll take up next time.
Yes, ma'am.
Not a problem. Okay. Okay,
thank you everyone for the attention. Yes,
Thanks, man. Thank you.
Ma'am, one question.
Thank you, ma'am.
please ask.
Thank you, ma'am.
Ma'am, one person.
This is CRF is like checking the context
and then deciding the tags or.
Please ask.
Yes,
conditional random 4 fields is you are
conditionally calculating the probability
based on the tag of the previous,
based on the named entity tag of the
previous word. So conditioning on that,
predicting the next word.
Okay.
Yeah, ma'am, one question like,
still my assignment one is not evaluated,
Yes.
Soon.
Yeah, yeah,
that I told now I have told a learning
is blank.
facilitators,
almost 90% of them have done.
I don't know why others you are able to
see.
Is there anybody who is able to see the
marks?
Yeah, ma'am, last week it was not there.
This week it is.
Yes, ma'am.
It's there, right? Yeah.
So most of them it is evaluated.
Yeah, yeah.
Looks like few of the groups are not yet
evaluated.
I will immediately tell the LF to do it
by end of tomorrow. Okay.
Welcome, yeah, thank you.
Thank you, ma'am.
Yes.
Ma'am, I have a small query, may I?
Yes, please ask.
As you explained about situated learning,
Huh, yes.
Actually,
I'm actually working in a school.
Huh.
So I was thinking where it could be
applied and role and need some guidance
over that.
Can I e-mail this matter to you? Yeah.
Sure, sure, sure. Yes, yes,
you can send the e-mail. No problem.
Yeah, because I need some clarity, ma'am,
on situated learning plus the school and
Should.
Sure, sure, you can, you can.
Yes, yes.
Only thing is next week is a little tight.
teaching, yeah.
I have been invited in some places for
giving expert session and also some
meetings,
but I will try my best to respond as soon
as possible.
Ma'am,
on an high level in schools like CBSE
schools, where could this NLP be applied?
Ma'am, advanced concepts of NLP.
You can apply in teaching actually.
My expert session on Monday for some,
this is on education only.
How can you use Gen.
AI and these things in education sector?
So maybe I will share with you.
I'm giving an expert session on that and
also.
invited as a chief guest.
So I will tell you there are a lot of
Yeah.
places where you can use.
Yeah, if possible,
please share some materials regarding.
There are tutors also, personal tutor,
you can customize your teaching, learning,
Mm.
assignments,
everything based on the students learning
capacity, etc.
So a lot of places you can use.
OK, ma'am,
and then lesson planning and taking a
parent feedback on,
so we are using that way.
Yes, yes, definitely, yes.
Okay, ma'am. Yeah. Thank you.
Okay, thank you everyone for your time.
Bye bye.
Thank you, ma'am.
Thank you.
KIRIT.